[音楽]
padi
私は
与勝のできよるなーっていう子の言葉に支えられています
親の低輝度な距離感で見守る
与勝ができよるなっていうこの言葉は子供のどげんかなりそうな気がする
ふうに何度も頑張る気持ちを育てると思っています
私は25年間たくさんの親子の方を見てきてそう感じました
なぜそう思うのか教
の話は私乳娘息子そして私の思いと話を進めていきます
あっの向こうから私の子供の頃の声が聞こえてきました
おとーさーんこれねやったら出来そうな気がするんだけど
あっダメか
じゃあこの方法でやってみたらと限界なあってきた
ってことは他のもできるやなかろうか
そうなんです私小学生の頃よく実家の果樹園の片隅で穴を掘っていました
ひたすら掘るんです
それは父が
お前ら見てみろあのあー方回ろうが地球の裏側にブラジルはあるとぞって言うんです
うちの実家のいとこは実はブラジルに住んでいて会いたくなったんですね
一つら彫りました大丈夫ですご心配ありません
マグマが噴き出したら傘で止めるという準備もしれました
またある時はアメリカ映画に
まあ
お父さんヘにプールがあるってよ私ね15m かけにコースぐらいつくる県お湯でを
通って言って掘っていると父はそれをこうを横目で見ながらロー
思い横つのできうるなーって言って仕事をそのまま続けていましたそんな父が実は果樹
園を1台で広げていきました
田舎のおっちゃんなのに子供の頃から私が言われたのは俺のライバルはアメリカや日本
の農業はアメリカの農業にやがて飲まれる件 z 裏負けんと言って周りが米を作って
いる時に早く武道に変え
ブドウが浸透してきたら高級品種の巨峰へと変えていきました
ああああああ
私が起業するといった時に生じキュート起こるカラーと思って
ちょっと相談しに行ってみたら
を燃やせ空氣目立つたっ
ひめたんなら
先は見て黄銅製そして人の仙骨ば先にせろ
って言われました
マッキーの病室だったんですけどね
そんな私がやがて親になり娘が高校1年生になりました
携帯電話を持ったんですそしたら最初の請求書が旧1,085円
はあはあっと私の中では思ってでも娘に姉姉姉姉将来どんな生活がしたいとといったら
娘はそうね一人暮らしでお部屋が3つ
はい消えた車がはい消えた旅行がはい消えたと思いながらもしらーん顔して一つ一つ
金額で換算していくとスキ
35万円の生活になったんですでもピンときません
ただ娘が初任給てー
くら野郎って言い出したんでああ私がやっている大学の保育課の猫の師求人には14万
て来てたよって言っ
マジと6号になりました長狭高校生活3年間を計算してみようかぁって言ったのねそし
たらそうだよね
地下鉄で来るとしたら糸島からに主人までと過食ヒート金1個ずつ計算していくと3
年間で
そう1,040,000円になったら今ね心が通じ合ったんですよ
はぁ
104がやになってねじゃあそれを今まで通りもらう方が良いそれとも一括にするって
言ったら
一括でって言うんです私を踏まず100万円のピン札の帯封ついたの peer と
投げました
すると敵はビビリもせずにどうもうって言って持って行ったんですよ
はぁっと分本5つここで皆さん家は金持ちでもありません
私繰り上げ返済をしようと思って家の借金返すためにコツコツ貯めてた100万円を
投げてしまったんです
で翌朝もう1回聞きましたすると娘がやりたいって言うんですね
陶業の大学行って一人暮らしするからその練習する通知をつくって管理するというので
もうねうちにはこれ以上のお金はない系って言いながら
思い切って待たせることにしました2年生の夏休み
ねぇあの時のことへお靴がパカパカなったよね制服のローファー
ここに座ったばっかりに私の
ねおもちゃにされはいそしてそのパカパカなっているのをイイとって言ったら娘がやや
母上
今月の桃が予算委員会ではリップと靴
比べたところリップの価値でございましたっていうのでへへー
でも歩きにくくないのって言ったらいや今なツヤ子結構涼しくていい
いいよって言うんですよロイ子やなぁと思って持っといて
まあそれから様々なことあるんですけど3年間無事キャット万円生活は終わりました
娘は予算を自分で管理して
しっかり計画して使っていくという大きな達成感を得たと私は思っています
ここからは息子の話ですもう少し前に登ります
息子が小学校1年生の時初めて家族旅行で夏の北海道に行きます
ちょうどその時私初めて子供の運動遊びの本を出版できる最終確認のときとか下がって
いました
まあこの本の出版も6でとなんで自分の価値だめだいっぱいの原稿を
ある教会の編集長のところに立ったって当て持っていってこれ売っ
台本にするともう子育て中のママと保育士の先生の役に立てる自信があるんですって
松野明美さんばりにですねプレゼンをやったんですけれども
やや黄味意味がわかんないと全部海されるんですねそこで企画書の書き方から勉強して
夢が叶うあと最後の一歩の確認のところが
この旅行と重なっていました
大雪山の2人乗りロープウェイに乗るときに電話が鳴ります
おっしょカラー
旦那も起こるだろうなぁここで撮ったらでも目はかかるよねー
追い切って取りましたそのロープウェイに乗るときも娘と息子がママと座るって喧嘩し
たのを増すことをスバル番だったんです
途中で息子がねえ飯まだっていうのも
線とごめんねー
そうなんです大雪山の深い緑が足元に広がっていました
時折エゾシカが飛んで九州では見ることのできない光景だったんです
息子は私に何度もそれを言うんですけどそのたんびにごめんね
電話を切ったのはロープウェイがつく時でした
降りる時に7歳の息子がママと見たかったのに
て呟きました私ずきんときました
なぜなら私はその月にもともと始めた自分の活動は娘と息子の友達づくりができたら
いいなっていう地域のボランティア活動からのスタートだったんです
でも徐々に活動が広がって子供を保育園に預けて
時に日曜日のイベントも映えるようになって
絶対子育て頑張ってると思うけどどこか寂しい思いさせてるんじゃないかなとか
自分の子供は保育園に預けて他の子供と遊ぶ仕事ってどうだろうとし文字通して滝と
だったからそのままと見たかったのには月と来てねがを見ながら思わず泣いてしまい
ました
やがて時が経って息子が大学生になりました
また偶然たまたまロープウェイに乗る時が起こりました
息子が1人乗りのロープウエーでグーッと登っていく後ろ姿を見ながらウッと思いまし
た
ああ昔はママと座るって喧嘩してたのに今となってはねねごめんちょっと乗ってみらん
って私がたドム立場になったんだなあと
そしてあの時の事をはっと思い出したんです
ロープウェイが到着して息子に謝りました
ごめんねーあんときさ私もいっぱいいっぱいでいろんなことあったっちゃけどほんの
ちょっとあんたたちに寂しい思いさせ取ったじゃないかなーって思ってさあ
というと息子は
はっ
そんなことあったっけごめん俺全然覚えてないして言うんです
まあまあそう言いながらね俺ねなんやかんやいいながらやりたいことを仕事にしていっ
た母ちゃんってさ
見てちょっとだけかっこいいなと思いよったよっ
言葉に15年間の自分と思いがサーッと溶けて
で
今仕事と子育てでパンパンに頑張っている
パパやママこの言葉を伝えたいんです
大丈夫です子どもは自分で成長していますそして親の後ろ姿を全部ひっくるめてみて
くれています
親が自分に自信を持つと
子どもを見守ることができます見守ることができれば
任せることができます
任せることが出来れば自身が育つと思うんです
さてここまで話して私の二人の息子のその後ちょっと聞いてみたくないですか
返事がなくても進めちゃうのが三木先生ですねっ
上の娘は東京に大学に進学して自分を高めてみたいからこの部署に入れてくださいと
言って
渋谷の it 企業でバリバリ働いています
息子は大阪の大学に進学したはずだったんですけれども
なぜか林業を志し大学を辞めて地元に帰ってきました
まあ昔から糸島から西陣まで自転車で顔用ような子で
大学大阪の大学行く時も自転車で行くようなちょっと変わった子だったんですけれども
東海道五十三次を歩いて旅をし江戸で足が止まらず東北まで行きそのパヴィの中で
出会った人々からたくさんの刺激を
てて
俺林業する林業で若者のつきたくなる職業にして絶対糸島の街を変えてみたい
日本全体が変わるかも知れ
朝倉の水害の時には朝4時半に電話がかかってきて俺だけこの仕事したいっちゃんが
チャット切れて何が起こったってなりました
のぐらい
2人の息子も娘も自分の穴を掘り続けてると思っています私はその二人を見ながら適度
な距離では誰しも自分の穴
何度でも起き上がる心の強い子どもを育てる運動塾を運営しています
私思うんですきっとこの私たちの姿を
空の上から乳が
抑圧のできよるなって見守ってくれてるんじゃないかな
だからできるんです子どもたちは自分で頑張ろうって思えるんですそんな子どもたちを
いっぱい育てていきたいなと思います
私言われたことがあるんです
オタクは女子供の会社でしょ
ちょっとだけ[ __ ]と思ったんですけれども
でも本当の事なんですね女性や子どもの多い会社だからこそ女性や子供がどんどん活躍
できて楽しめるようなアイディアで今後も授業していきたいなーって思っています
最後に
何度でも頑張る気持ちが大事だよ
これは私が行っている運動スクールの小学生の子どもが服ってくれた標語ですし
しんどいときにこの言葉をするとちょっとだけ頑張る気持ちになります
ありがとうございました
[拍手]